but even the idea that porn is without
consequence you know what people view
sex is without consequence but of course
marriage traditionally understood is
intended for the good of the spouses and
for the sake of the generation and
education of children yeah that it's a
real love a love that is so real that it
actually becomes in fleshed in this real
new person yeah who and hopefully many
new people who you know are a result of
that love yeah we divorce all even our
popular culture yeah we live in a very
contraceptive culture yeah well yes well
it also it's just there's there's a
there's a huge difference between love
and lust yeah I think they're so
different they're not similar they're
polar opposite yeah one selfish one
selfless yes you know one's very
sacrificial and one cost you something
and one's easy and it's and you you're
compromised right and what's about me
one's about self-control one's about
giving in to myself